I'm a little bit scared because I know
that Australia has animals that could
kill me
I've heard that kangaroos are really
strong and they liked a box I'm very
scared to meet an animal that knows that
a box I feel like this is going to be an
Alice in Wonderland have experience in
which I'm going to go through the
looking-glass and wind up somewhere that
I don't even think is real I expect to
lay on the ground and cuddle with at
least three chambers this is real this
is really ever we've just taken the
ferry and now we're about to go into the
sky to meet koalas
oh my god they're all just chillin
holy [ __ ] literally just laying there
what an amazing union of ANFO
oh my god
I think I've found my spirit animal I'm
really into this echidna I'm yeah now
baby woke up their numbers are declining
because they're being hunted because
they'll being hunted originally but now
they're only found or robbed they found
they once were found throughout
Australia this is like the perfect
animal I can't believe somebody would
actually want to hunt this is like the
most adorable thing I've ever seen in my
life
this is bonkers
Oh oh hello
I can't believe you're real it looks
like a soft Anna
oh it's moving oh my god oh hi it's so
chill
it's the chillest creature on earth it's
like all of the stuffed animals from my
childhood came alive I kind of feel like
I'm still dreaming like that didn't just
happen
I feel really changed I have a new dream
job and it's to be an Australian
zookeeper a lot of animals or even other
places you only think of them through TV
or the internet or our children's
storybooks and to actually be able to
experience it was really really special
it's like I'm gonna tell my children
about this someday and they're gonna be
like no you didn't I still can't get
over that a quokka licked my cheek I
think my favorite was for sure the caca
because like it's like a happy bunny
rabbit to be honest it's gonna be hard
to eat meat after this I would 100% come
back here like I want to come back in an
hour they're absolutely beautiful
amazing creatures caca is this who you
party with kangaroo is who you hang out
with and the echidna is a person that's
a little bit too cool for you